This is what I love about HR. You learn these little intricacies about people
Margaret's gonna show us the meaning of trust
Honey, what am I really doing this summer? I mean, I sent the kids away to camp
I'm redesigning bathrooms
Think Brooklyn, exposed brick, and a urinal
Meg wants me standing up again
Yeah
New neighbors aren't wasting any time moving in, are they?
Hey, honey! Still spying on the neighbors?
Hi. We're the Joneses
Such a lovely street. The Chinese don't even have a word for a street like this
They would say (chinese)
It sounds cool coming out of your mouth
You don't think there's something off about them
They're both so overly accomplished and stylish
Welcome to the Cobra Club. Little different than you expected huh?
That looks like a real snake. Snake one. That's real cobra
Do you have tab?
I'm following Natalie Jones
Hello Karen
Natalie!
I was just leaving Tim a voicemail. He likes to hear from me when I'm trying on lingerie
It's one of our things. Do you and Jeff have a thing?
We do it really fast in case the kids come running into our room
Who are these people? We need evidence. I just wanna make sure this is not paranoia
What is this?
There's a missile
That's me
What is all this stuff?
Honey is that you? Mama wants to cuddle
The Joneses, they're not who they say they are
Here's the thing about trust, once it's gone, bad things can happen
This is Joneses. Get the car now
When I count to three we're gonna run, okay?
One, two
Oh my god
Jeff!
You can't be serious
I was making a head start!
On your wife?
Hello, sweetie. No, the cookies are for both of you. Well just split the last one
Just split the cookie! Split the cookie!
This tie's been fitted with a miniature surveillance mic. It's completely undetectable
Help! Help!
Jeff!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, wait!
We don't get out very often so we really like to make the most of it